Aaron you and I've been playing a lot of
ghost recon break point we have mixed
opinions I'd say we have a review on the
way from Richard way cling but right now
you can read his review impressions for
the most part he is said that it's
glitchy buggy there's the AI is not
super great and it feels very much like
Ubisoft game yeah all right so let's dig
into that that was the initial 10 hour
impression you and I are a bit further
into the game now I think I'm around
level 60 or 70 right yeah and the raid
is still a ways off it's weird that this
game has a raid but let's talk about how
like the basic systems of this game kind
of clash with each other mm-hmm so this
is supposed to be a you know a stealth
game with light survival elements where
you're trapped on an island what it
actually is moment a moment is a looter
shooter which is kind of against the
idea of a stealth game now here's the
thing you can play this game as a
stealth game and you actually will
probably get more enjoyment out of it
doing it that way I think that's the
most I guess tactical way to play right
because you're aiming for headshots
you're playing silence you're doing
stealth kills you're not really engaging
with that spongy aspect of a loot
shooter so that I think is the best way
to play it especially with friends and
you guys are sneaking around and I think
when they like the feeling of being
hunted is actually kind of cool right
like when there's drones overhead and
you kind of panic for a second you hop
on the ground hiding grass maybe cover
yourself with with mud or whatever to
get away from it like that that feeling
is kind of cool there are some genuinely
cool moments like that it's almost as if
you have to roleplay in this game like I
think you know one of our Coker's Matt
was saying that when his stealth gets
blown he kind of just gives up
you don't have to I mean you can just go
loud in this game when you do that I
feel like that's when the AI really
breaks down for example they'll funnel
up a hallway and mass until you've
gunned them all down or like just
sometimes stop functioning when you just
start dating I will say that if you
crank it up to a harder difficulty I'm
playing on advanced right now which i
think is the penultimate difficulty the
AI doesn't feel bad and I know a couple
people have said
including our reviewers that the AI is
not very great you've had bad experience
to the Vai I've definitely run into bugs
with the AI but they're a little bit
more aggressive I see them trying out
different tactics they're not always
successful with these tactics but they
in some sense kept me on my toes I'm not
saying the AI is fantastic
but I didn't think it was terrible and
I've had some genuinely great moments in
coop like crawling across a field for my
life while being covered by friends or
like you know somebody on overwatch
saving your butt at the last minute and
you know like you do have those tense
moments when you play with other people
on the right difficulty yeah like I was
playing with Mike McCarty and our
helicopter got shot down we went down in
the middle of nowhere we were like two
kilometres away from our objective and
all these patrols started merging on us
because we crashed the helicopter
essentially and immediately weak
scrambled or like how are we gonna get
out of this so we hid kind of
repositioned ourselves and use that
helicopter crashes distraction to take
out all these squads and that was really
cool and that felt really good the only
issue is that that is one short moment
of a lot of moments of just loot
shooting like traveling in a helicopter
for a long time traveling like trying to
get from point A to point B watching an
animation of you setting up a camp every
single oh my god they really do need a
button that just says please activate
this camp yeah I do not want to go into
this camp I have you found a way to skip
it because I haven't found a way to skip
it maybe I'm just not hitting the right
button maybe they'll patch that in at
some point but yeah I haven't been able
to skip it and there are long animations
and that's another thing about
difficulty too right because if you plan
on easy difficulty there's no reason to
use these bivouacs which i think could
be a huge part of a game but if you're
playing on easy like what's the point
okay that's that's actually a really
good point though to talk about endgame
so here's my fear we've all put a bunch
of hours into this game right now games
like this like destiny for example that
where loot shooters kind of throw away
the first I don't know X hours 10 20 30
hours they just throw them away because
you're really just trying to get to like
you know the legendary gear and then
engage in the real game division - was
was it did a better job kind of like
that
yeah these games are getting better at
leading you into that endgame I would
say but yeah to your point so but my
fear is that the first like and I can't
confirm this or not but the first part
of this game is kind of miserable and
against the stealth aspects with all the
collec getting distracted by collecting
loot and like no need to craft because
you're just always getting handed guns
because there's something that they want
you to do at the end they keep hinting
they want you to fight you know like the
Hemus and high-level robots and there's
a raid coming but you know it breaks my
brain I do a raid in a Ghost Recon game
I don't understand it you know they're
heading in that division direction
it's just games like this potentially
and I'm not saying it's the case here
because I don't know yet they keep like
throwing away the meat of their game and
tacking it on to the end so you have a
pretty like mediocre experience until
you hit this point and we haven't hit
that point yet so that's my fear that
you do need to start crafting at some
point and yeah that is a fair fear or
that I see that however the the thing
with the thing with games like the
division and destiny is that even though
a lot of that beginning middle section
is kind of throwaway engaging with the
game is still fun there are still like
good enemies to fight there's there's a
good feeling when you pull the trigger
and games like destiny and things like
that this has its moments right like you
score headshots you clear base stealthy
that's fine but the UI is kind of a mess
the like it just doesn't feel as as
polished as a game like destiny or even
the division there are so many immersion
breaking moments - like the prison
mission you just mentioned it asks you
to rescue prisoners
when you open the cell the prisoners are
just standing there with a rifle
you're the Lord I've had bugs where my
my my coop buddy who I'm playing with
his he's outside of a helicopter that
he's flying for some reason which are
kind of funny like sure they're emerging
breaking but at least they're not game
breaking right like I can still play it
I roll my eyes at it I've had NPCs like
main NPCs not follow me out of hot zones
and I okay legitimately had to knock
them out with a helicopter and then
revived them in order to get them to
like address someone out with a
helicopter you know I got some
helicopter skills but I think the other
big thing to talk about with this game
too are the microtransactions which have
been a hot-button issue I would say
since this game what on Tuesday hit the
early access to be fair I think that
they were just recently they removed the
most egregious ones that people were
upset about yeah there's a lot of like
you know we're talking about all the
systems in this game there's just a lot
of systems in this game one of them
looks like kind of a battle pass and
it's just really unclear what it's doing
there and then I think that fed into
what you're talking about where you
could pay that maybe progress in that
system and but you don't need to like
yeah from what I've played I haven't
felt the need to pay for anything but
once again like you were saying about
endgame maybe when you get to the
endgame you're gonna have to do a lot of
grinding unless you want to pay but I
don't know that because I haven't hit
the endgame yet but where I am now I
haven't really felt the need to buy
anything I haven't even felt the need to
craft anything because that everything
is not particularly difficult at least
at unnormal you got a mean look in your
eye you got big plans the last thing I
do wanna mention is that the story which
oddly enough they put more of a focus on
this game because wildlands got a lot of
heat for a it's setting and be just how
poorly written it was like almost to the
point of being a comedy I would say like
some of the things your soldiers would
say where it ridiculous and this they
decided to double down on the story but
it's not better but it's also not bad
enough to be funny so it's just kind of
there and what makes it worse is that
you're kind of forced to watch these
cutscenes like sure you can skip through
some of them but if you're like me and
you have no interest in this story and
it has
than anything to hook me so there's no
reason for me to be interested in this
story you have to watch a ton of
cutscenes a ton of conversations with
characters I don't care about with bad
voice-acting and it is just it's it's
rough like at least wildlands had that
at least said that pacing where you can
move from one outpost to the next and
you weren't constantly returning to this
hub area where you had to essentially
sit down and watch a bunch of cutscenes
okay so I just want to say that we are
not the people reviewing this game this
is you know are pictured waking that
should be up next week hopefully and I
will say you know like I think there's a
lot of negative points in this game but
if you are willing to do and this was
similar in wild lands if you're willing
to roleplay with the AI in this game and
force yourself to play this game
stealthy with friends on the right
difficulty I think there are some really
fun moments today that totally totally
I've had some great moments in this game
and a lot of people argue that oh well I
mean co-op games by nature are more fun
and I do agree with that but there are
some situations that you couldn't be in
by yourself that you can be with a
friend or with a couple friends that I
think make for some really interesting
encounters it's just all the other stuff
that gets in the way that keeps you from
moving from those really interesting fun
situations to the next I feel like the
game is actively trying to push those
situations away from you which is
frustrating you know we'll see how this
game develops there might be an end game
there that a lot of people just haven't
not to yet and feel free to leave your
thoughts in the comments below is this
the sequel to wild lands you've been
waiting for for me no but you know let
us know alright thanks for watching
you